i think we're ready now to tackle some
more or even more complicated examples
so let's draw something crazy here so
let's see let me draw
a chain
let me
draw it
like
that
and so like we've done in all of the
examples you want to find the longest
chain we could count from here one two
three four five six seven eight or maybe
it's one two three four five six seven
no or maybe it's one two three four 5 6
7 8 9
10. that is our longest chain
let me just let me make that in green so
our longest chain here is in green
so this decade this sorry this backbone
has 10 carbons in it the prefix 410 is
dec it is a alkane since it has all
single bonds so we can write decane for
the backbone and then it has a group
right here it has a group right here
and this group consists of one two
carbons attached to the backbone the
prefix for two carbons is f so this is
an ethyl group the yl is because it's a
group attached to the main alkane chain
so we call this ethyl
ethyl decane we have to specify where
the ethyl group is attached and we want
to give it as low of a number as
possible so we start counting on the
side closest to it so it's one two
three four
five so this is five
ethyl
decay now let's complicate this a little
bit more
so let me just copy and paste this
copy
and then
paste
so i have pasted it there and let me
complicate this molecule a little bit
more let me add another ethyl group to
it
let me add another ethyl group to it so
let's say it is we have another
ethyl group over there now what is this
going to be well we still the longest
chain is still going to be that thing in
green so it's still going to be a decane
it's still going to be a decade but now
we have two ethyl groups one on the five
carbon one two three four five and then
one on the six carbon and then one on
the six carbon so what we write here is
you might be tempted to write five ethyl
six ethyl decane which really wouldn't
be wrong but it would just be maybe more
letters than you want to write instead
you're right
instead you write five
comma six
diethyl
diethyl
diethyl decane the 5 6 tells us the two
carbons on the main backbone that the
ethyl groups are attached to and the dye
says that we have two ethanes or two
ethyl groups i should say not ethane
groups two ethyl groups one over here
and one
right over here